as a rule I don't talk about leaked
footage so I was not gonna have to talk
about Suicide Squad then they release
the trailer in HD so now I have two
Suicide Squad so here we have the second
fit of footage to come out dealing with
the DC Cinematic Universe after Batman V
Superman and I'm inclined to be a little
more favorable towards this one that I
was - Batman V Superman even though I
find things to both get intrigued about
and to sort of be concerned about in
both cases the reason I'm gonna be a
little bit nicer to this one is it
wasn't designed to be a proper trailer
it was made just for San Diego comic-con
and what's in it is designed to
specifically motivate that audience I
mean this thing tells us virtually
nothing about the story so it wasn't
really designed to sell the movie
overall to the general public the way
the Batman V Superman trailer was and
along those lines I think that's why
certain things like how heavily Harley
Quinn gets featured is in this I don't
think it's necessarily representative of
the fact that Harley Quinn is like the
go-to character I think it's just an
indicator that they knew their audience
and comic-con audiences loved Harley
Quinn but let's get to the beginning of
the singing we'll start with the thing
that I like the most I am sold on Amanda
Waller won Viola Davis was cast I don't
want to say it was skeptical but I was
disappointed because I really wanted
them to catch someone who was more in
line with the traditional body type for
Amanda Waller but her line delivery and
also did the actual lines that they were
having her say awesome sold as for the
rest of the cast honestly there isn't
all that much to go on cuz it is just
all these little snippets without
context and you don't get a ton of
flavor for the carriages you get to see
what they look like and on that note
Killer Croc looks way better than I
thought he was going to when we first
saw the still image of him didn't like
it but when he's properly lit and in
motion yeah looks good
I'm slightly concerned about Will Smith
as Deadshot I do believe he can play the
part but he got all the kind of cheesy
little lines that got thrown in there
that I'm hoping they are only cheesy cuz
we're getting them isolated I'm hoping
in the context of whatever scene those
lines are from they'll work better but
the other thing I gotta say about
Deadshot and I feel like I'm alone on
this but I hate the mask I think it
looks like a paintball mask but let's
get to the thing that everybody is
talking about coming out of this Jared
Leto's Joker
which is another thing I'm nervous about
now I'm not saying he's not gonna be
good and I'm not saying it sucks I won't
make that call yet I will however say
I'm still not sold and the fact that I'm
still not sold has me nervous I am gonna
have to talk about Heath Ledger's Joker
just briefly to sort of give context to
this when he was first cast like I think
everybody I was skeptical as hell the
first real bit of the performance we got
was in the very first teaser which had
no visuals to it at all it was just it
was the bat-signal sort of breaking up
with audio laid over that so we heard
him for the first time that didn't sell
me either because his line delivery and
isolation wasn't working for me when we
got the first proper trailer and we saw
the makeup and we saw the performance
and I saw that voice and you know the
way he was twitchy and everything just
the whole package then I saw that went
awesome I want to see more of this I'm
on board we are now at that same
comparable point with Jared Leto
and I'm still not sold it's far enough
along I'm starting to get concerned that
they're not gonna be able to sell me on
this character I think what is it
working for me about this joker so far
is that it feels very artificial it
feels like an affectation it just has
this kind of force Hey look at me I'm
crazy thing going on that's that's just
not working for me and I I don't think I
have tunnel vision on the Joker must be
this I think the Joker is one of the
most infinitely reinterpret able
characters in popular culture there's
almost no interpretation that I've seen
of the character that I haven't liked
but this one's still not clicking with
me and that makes me nervous I mean I
I'm not writing it off yet I'm still
waiting to be turned around but it
hasn't happened yet so I think that
pretty much covers everything I wanted
to talk about with Suicide Squad I'm
assuming you probably saw the thing by
now what were your thoughts on it
whatever they were drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]